we've talked quite a bit about
intelligence on this program
some examples are we've had discussions
about cognitive abilities we've talked
about behavioral economics we've talked
about the dunning-kruger phenomenon to
the extent that it's valid I known it
that now there are some recent questions
about to what extent is it valid we've
spoken about moral psychology we've
talked about the right-wing effort to
smear higher education as liberal
indoctrination I've spoken a lot about
pseudo versus anti intellectualism we've
also talked about education in the
aggregate in the United States where we
see rising education on average right
people are more educated than ever more
college degrees but there's a sort of
ugly aspect in terms of that growing
college educated population which is the
growing intellectual divide the sort of
inequality in education and the
cognitive divide that is growing and
that's what I want to talk about today
Nick medjool II wrote a really good
article about this on his blog called
of dollars and data and it's mostly like
a wonky personal finance website but he
has a really good article called the
cognitive aristocracy and it was
recommended to me by Barry Ritholtz 'iz
newsletter which I encourage you to get
on if you don't know who Barry Ritholtz
is google him get on his newsletter
really really good reading
recommendations there um and what Nick
Manjula points out is that we have a
situation where on the one hand in the
United States we have more people with
college degrees than ever as a
percentage of the population on the
other hand we have academic achievement
by American students in math and science
and reading really lagging behind other
countries and not improving either
falling further and further behind many
other countries so let's put aside for a
second the questions about the value of
standardized testing as a way to measure
this because I agree standardized
testing is not a great measure of total
cognitive
but for today we can consider it sort of
a proxy to think about what's going on
what we have is a status quo where
Americans are more educated than ever in
total but are lagging more and more in
actual academic achievement and one of
the reasons for this is that over time
the people who are most likely to go to
college are coming more and more from
those with the most cognitive ability
okay you can see that since the early
1900's people at all cognitive levels
are going to college more but at the top
people in the 90th percentile of
cognitive ability people in the 75th
percentile of cognitive ability their
college attendance has increased by
significantly more than those who don't
do as well on cognitive tests now all
sorts of things are said about IQ many
of those things are controversial and
many of those things we've debunked
because they're flat-out wrong but as
I'm going to point out in the next
couple of weeks in a follow-up on the
race and IQ topic there is something
that IQ does really well which is it
screens out people who are seriously
cognitively limited so what we're
learning more and more is that people
who have IQs of 150 don't really do much
better in life than people who have IQs
of 120 or 105 but that when IQ is
particularly low which really just tells
us that certain cognitive abilities are
really lacking that is a significant
negative indicator in terms of future
success so we can debate whether college
is the path forward for career success
the answer is in our economy it's
generally helpful but in the new economy
it might be more circumstance dependent
but the impact of all of this is that
the workforce is increasingly divided
into two groups well educated
professionals are seeing rising wages
most workers are in stagnant wage jobs
with little opportunity
for advancement and this is correlating
with increasingly having two groups in
terms of intellect as well and the sort
of downside one of the downsides of our
system is that we often fail to identify
poor and minority students who could do
really well with higher education but
they're simply not identified as having
that potential and then they suffer and
in principle there's no problem simply
because different people have different
education levels you would expect in a
world where equality of outcome is not
realistically to be expected that you're
going to end up with people with
different educational levels the problem
is that education is correlating with
income and income correlates with all
sorts of divides in society from a
cultural perspective the biggest problem
is that ignorant and lack of education
are increasingly seeing as a badge of
honor in some circles we've talked about
how on the Republican side there is more
and more demonization of higher
education as liberal indoctrination in
the short term this helps Republicans
get elected because you have people who
are proud of not being educated or of
being anti intellectuals and they're
overwhelmingly voting for Republicans so
in the short term this actually has a
political consequence of helping
Republicans in the long term though this
could destroy our country as we know it
by creating a sort of even more
permanent underclass and I say even more
permanent because class mobility is
difficult enough as it is if you're born
poor you're overwhelmingly likely to
remain poor for the rest of your life
it's going to be even more difficult if
this correlation between education
intellect cognitive achievement and
income continues to grow and the sort of
partisan analysis is yeah a lot of these
people just write off education is
liberal nonsense too bad for them
that's fine from a political perspective
but this goes way beyond politics in
that it affects people way more on the
basis of economic class
on the basis of politics it affects
people way more on the basis of minority
status than on the basis of their
politics and there is zero chance that
Republicans fix it
between gutting public education and
seeing college as liberal nonsense and
pushing charter schools at the expense
of public schools Republicans I mean
there is zero chance they are going to
fix it it's something that has to change
and to play politics with it is fine it
doesn't help the left though because of
the issue that educated people tend to
vote more liberally but it's a far
bigger structural problem a sort of
cognitive and intellectual underclass
that is rapidly developing in the United
States of America